e
[Aplausos]
em agosto de 2019 eu perdi minha mãe de
uma maneira muito repentina
tanto ela quanto o meu pai a Leni e o
manu
eles vivem camarão com sete anos de
diferença entre uma passagem outra mas
exatamente da mesma maneira
um AVC hemorrágico
repentino e sem chance de Socorro médico
é um soco seco no estômago de quem fica
Porque
alguns segundos estantes a gente tinha a
pessoa ali ao nosso lado e de repente
é aquela história de vida não existe
mais
Olá meus pais me deixaram muitas
heranças
tanto em aprendizado porque eles eram
pessoas incríveis maravilhosas
mas também bens e um desses bens eram
restaurante com quase duas décadas de
existência
localizado no coração financeiro de São
Paulo ali na região da Avenida Paulista
é
assim que minha mãe faleceu eu decidi
continuar com aquela história do
restaurante mesmo aquilo não sendo meu
sonho eu nunca sonhei ter um restaurante
mas eu entendia que era importante para
ela e que era importante para mim
ressignificar a história dos meus pais e
significado tudo que eles tinham
construído e deixado como legado
Então já decidida quando a pandemia
pegou todo mundo de surpresa eu não tive
dúvidas mesmo estando à frente de uma
empresa na área de serviços que foi uma
das áreas mais atingidas ali naquele
momento eu decidi continuar Porque para
mim eu já tava vivendo o maior desafio
da minha vida eu tinha perdido a minha
mãe Minha sócia minha grande companheira
Oi e aí Aline março de 2020 eu fiz o que
todo mundo que comandava uma empresa
naquele momento Ou pelo menos deveria
ter feito que foi
refazer rota repensar os caminhos traçar
novas estratégias e deu certo pelo menos
os primeiros quatro meses ali de
pandemia deu muito certo eu consegui
trazer investimentos de fora para dentro
do restaurante nós reestruturamos um
modelo de negócio conseguir fazer com
que adiar o uso do nosso fluxo de caixa
deu tudo certo comigo trabalhando de 12
a 15 horas por dia
trabalhando bastante porque era
necessário naquele momento e
principalmente porque parte da equipe
tinha ficado em casa por conta da gente
acreditar que era necessário diminuir o
número de pessoas circulando ali naquele
momento em que a gente não sabia nada
ainda sobre a pandemia e porque eu tinha
muita gente dentro da minha o que era do
grupo de risco
e quando a gente já tava ali vivendo um
seis meses de pandemia e já todo mundo
bem assustado porque o que parecia ser
dois ou três meses a mostrava para gente
que era algo sem controle quem tava
trabalhando no restaurante todos os dias
tava completamente cansado
eu então nem se fala simplesmente
acabada Porque eu trabalhava 12 15 horas
por dia
eu fazia de tudo se você ligasse no
restaurante e pedir comida pelo telefone
provavelmente eu que atendia se você
fizesse uma reclamação no SAC e eu
respondia se você ligasse pedisse ou se
você pedisse comida pelo aplicativo com
certeza eu que ia responder a mensagem
eu lavável entregável montava eu criava
cardápios eu negociava dívidas com o
banco eu ia atrás de fornecedores eu
limpava trocar e da trocava pista quente
eu desentupi a banheiro eu tinha feito
da minha existência
o significado de lugar
a sobreviver aquela crise para mim era o
principal naquele momento
é
a grande questão é que eu nunca tinha
sonhado em ser
empresária do ramo gastronômico
o meu sonho sempre foi ser jornalista
a
apresentadora de televisão
e eu desde pequena eu brincava com
microfones eu não brincava com panelas
mas eu tinha entendido para mim é
importante
seguir aquela história que os meus pais
tinham traçado eu sabia o quão
importante era eu ser uma das poucas
mulheres negras aqui no país a ser uma
empresária no ramo de restaurante num
dos lugares mais importantes do Brasil
bom e quando a gente já tava lá chegando
no final de 2020 nove dez meses de
pandemia as coisas foram ficando ainda
mais difíceis e essa pessoa que
trabalhava 12 e 15 horas por dia
enlouquecida ainda era a mesma pessoa
que no final do dia linda e bela
maquiada dá uma entrevista no jornal na
revista na televisão porque eu era o
símbolo do Empreendedor que não desiste
nunca
e esse não desistir nunca
e me mostrou
É que na verdade nem sempre persistência
Esse é o que muda e traz felicidade
porque ali em dezembro de 2020 eu estava
completamente esgotada e infeliz
mas agindo em cima da teimosia eu não
cogitava desistir
desistir para mim ela é impossível eu
tinha que vencer aquele obstáculo eu
tinha que ultrapassar aquela crise eu
não aceitava
e eu não aceitava de jeito nenhum em
janeiro de 2021 a gente compra todo 18
anos eu mandei colocar uma placa na
porta do restaurante
Não desistiremos nunca os nossos 18 anos
estão apenas começando
É que na verdade aquela placa Nunca nem
fez sentido para mim
e eu entrava naquele restaurante
olhava aquela placa e tentava entender o
que eu tava fazendo o quê que eu tava
vivendo
e talvez efeito sentido para as pessoas
que passaram ali na porta que entraram
no restaurante quando já foi permitido
frequentar novamente os estabelecimentos
só para mim não fazia
e eu precisava encontrar no meio da
minha angústia e da infelicidade que eu
tava criando ali naquele momento um novo
sentido para minha vida
e eu na verdade me sentia muito
frustrada e frustração é um sentimento
doloroso demais para ser saboreado é
impossível de Saborear
mas àquela altura eu já recebi alguns
sinais do universo o universo já tava me
convidando para fazer trabalhos de
comunicação que na verdade eu nunca
deixei de lado muito pelo contrário eu
fiz a loucura de trabalhar aquelas 12 e
15 horas por dia sem empreendedora que
era o símbolo do não desisto nunca e
ainda no final de semana fazer um extra
mediando eventos em do Mestre de
Cerimônia online e utilizando o dinheiro
que para curtir o restaurante porque
naquele momento o sucesso dos quatro
meses iniciais esse já tinha ido para o
saco né Eu Já devia muito dinheiro na
praça já não recebia investimentos de
fora já não tinha mais energia para
pensar cardápio na verdade eu não tinha
energia nem para ultrapassar a porta e
lê de novo a placa do não desisto nunca
e já completamente infeliz em satisfeita
buscando
compreender qual caminho seguir e
tentando tomar coragem
[Música]
e eu fui atrás de uma oração que eu
fazia todos os dias mas eu não sei não
entendi a Na verdade o Real sentido
e todo dia eu pedi a serenidade para
aceitar as coisas que não posso
modificar
a coragem para modificar aquelas que eu
posso e sabedoria para reconhecer a
diferença entre elas
é mas aquele dia ali no final de janeiro
já completamente esgotada e querendo
vencer o medo de desistir Essa oração
e me deu um significado
eu consegui dizer para mim mesma chega
e chega Cristiane
em desistir não é feio
e eu tinha medo de desistir
a gente vive ainda mais no meio do
empreendedorismo uma força imensa para
que você acredite que vai que sempre vai
dar certo que desistir não é a melhor
opção só que a gente não pode deixar que
a teimosia
ultrapasse os limites quando o mundo
inteiro tava me mostrando que não dava
mais eu tinha tentado E aí vem um dos
meus primeiros aprendizados
tentar necessário eu tentei eu não
consegui não foi porque eu não fui
competente eu não consegui porque
existiam situações que eram
completamente adversas as forças que eu
tinha para entregar ali naquele momento
Oi e aí
18 anos da história que os meus pais
tinham traçado lindamente não precisavam
mais pesar nas minhas costas como 200
300 kg eu podia reescrever a minha
história
é claro que não foi fácil finalizar tudo
aquilo porque eu já tinha várias dívidas
então eu precisei de novo recalcular
Rota e pensar como fechar como demitir a
equipe pagar as rescisões e atrás de
empréstimos para poder resolver
minimamente as questões atuais e as
dificuldades que eu tinha ali naquele
momento
mas eu já tinha o chamado do universo e
aí foi que eu decidi aceitar um convite
para se a primeira
apresentadora do primeiro programa que
reúne uma editora Negra apresentadora
Negra e diretora Negra na TV Cultura
eu decidi também fechar o restaurante
abrir a minha empresa de comunicação
Oi e o universo sempre colocando a meu
favor me auxiliou e eu consegui até
fechar dois primeiros contratos e
grandes contratos com essa empresa de
comunicação no momento que eu entendi
qual que era o meu caminho
e eu tinha medo de desistir
é só que eu tinha transformado a busca
e pela existência daquele restaurante e
feito com que aquilo se tornasse muito
maior do que eu
e não dá para existir felicidade
quando aquilo que a gente busca é maior
do que a nossa resistência
foi um outro aprendizado
e eu precisava ressignificar o fim do
restaurante E aí eu decidi que nos
últimos dias em que nós ficássemos
abertos nós víamos servir comida para
pessoas em situação de rua o sonho da
minha mãe sempre foi cozinhar uma comida
que curasse as pessoas e ela curou
ao longo dos 17 anos dela à frente do
restaurante ela conseguiu curar muita
gente e aí eu decidi que naquele final a
gente ia re-significar e dar comida para
as pessoas que estavam um talvez mais
vulneráveis naquele momento tão
vulneráveis quanto eu que mesmo tendo
tudo emocionalmente tava completamente
destruída
a e foi muito engraçado porque não dos
últimos dias em que a gente cozinhou uma
pessoa falou nossa comida tão gostosa eu
me sinto curada quando como
e a gente realmente tinha conseguido
em diante de tudo isso que eu vivi
é um dos meus maiores aprendizados foi
que eu preciso jogar a luz para entender
que tem um Limiar muito Sutil entre
persistência e teimosia
Oi e a morte repentina dos meus pais
e me ensinou
que a vida não espera
E aí
que
a vida não espera
e ela nunca vai esperar a gente ficar
insistindo em viver uma história que não
nos faz feliz
tô ciente de que a vida não espera
é a minha única escolha
e é viver a vida dos meus sons
a
tentar sempre necessário
eu não consegui é intensamente
frustrante só que se Reinventar a
é muito glorioso
bom obrigada
E aí